I'm in Gävle, a city in Sweden, about a hundred
miles north of Stockholm.
And every year, they have a Christmas tradition:
build an enormous goat out of straw and put
it in the town square.
It's called the Gävle Goat.
There is a second Christmas tradition in Gävle.
Burning the goat down.
It's not like Guy Fawkes' Night in Britain,
or Burning Man in California,
where something is built to be burned down.
Burning this down is arson, it is completely
illegal,
and genuinely, the people who make the giant
straw goat
do not want their giant straw goat to be burned
down.
Giant straw goats are expensive.
It's just that in the fifty years that a ten-metre-high,
mostly-unprotected goat
made of extremely flammable straw has been
put up here,
the goat has only survived twelve times.
Usually, it's burned down.
In 1976, it was hit by a car.
In 1979, it was burned down before it even
made it here.
In 1988, you could place a bet on whether
the goat would burn down.
Or at least you could, until the goat burned
down.
In 2001, an American tourist burned it down,
and when he was arrested
he said his friends had told him that burning
the goat was an entirely legal tradition.
He got a couple of weeks in jail, didn't get
his cigarette lighter back,
and left Sweden without paying a large fine.
In 2005, vandals dressed as Santa Claus and
gingerbread men
fired a burning arrow at the goat and burned
it down.
In 2006, the city fireproofed the goat.
It burned down.
In 2009, there were webcams set up to spot
vandals.
Those cameras were taken offline with a denial
of service attack
just before the goat burned down.
In 2011, they sprayed the goat with water
to form a protective coat of ice.
It burned down.
It is massive and it is made of tinder,
it is really, really easy to burn down this
goat.
Now, the local fire brigade are only two minutes
away, and sometimes they win.
In 2014, despite three arson attempts, the
goat did survive.
And now, it's 2016, the goat was put up just
a few days ago,
and as I record this, it's still there.
All it takes to create a tradition like this
is the same thing happening for a few years
in a row.
This goat wouldn't be famous if it didn't
burn down.
I wouldn't be here.
This would just be a small local display.
But every year, someone takes the risk of
a fine and criminal record and time in jail
to try and burn down someone else's hard work,
probably because they're drunk when they do
it.
And that strange, in-the-shadows, battle,
that almost sitcom-like plot,
gets the world interested,
and sends a few tourists to a fairly obscure
Swedish city.
Place your bets.
Quick update: I'm back in London, just landed
at Heathrow airport,
literally just a few hours after filming that.
The goat has already been burned to the ground.